bachelor nation we all know the deal Ben
Higgins used to date Jojo Fletcher he
even told her he loved her on TV but he
proposed to Lauren Bushnell and Jojo is
now engaged to Jordan Rogers but on Ben
and Lauren's new reality show happily
ever after the four of them all go on a
double date how crazy is this et caught
up with the couples at the iHeartRadio
Music Festival in Las Vegas the big
question was the date as awkward as the
promos make it see whenever you sit down
with people that you've dated before
it's gonna be a little awkward for at
least a start I'd never met them so
she's kept saying great things about him
but they're awesome I mean not only have
they been where we're at so he can give
some brotherly Big Brother advice but
they're great people good friends I'm
loving getting to know Ben and she has
great friends and so I have found
somebody he is with Lauren we're both
super happy and we can kind of just
rejoice in that together it was great it
was a good thing for us both to do
Jordan Jojo are awesome they're they're
happy and it was kind of good for us to
just kind of support each other and know
that like all the weirdness aside like
we're Bost our new relationships
you